marion cotillard bonjour je suis ravi de
recevoir alors on parle aujourd'hui d'un
film événement est maintenant pour
plusieurs raisons déjà l'ouverture de ce
64e festival de cannes c'est annette et
puis le retour de leos carax un
réalisateur singulier précieux rare
c'est son sixième long métrage en
presque quarante ans comment est-ce qui
vous a parlé de ce film comment est-ce
qui vous a présenté ce film il m'a
présenté souvent comme une comédie
musicale
on s'est rencontré il ya cinq ans
j'étais pas disponible à ce moment là
nous je lui dis tout de suite même si
c'était dur parce que dira un
réalisateur qui fait si peu de films
comme vous l'avez dit que l or n est pas
disponible c'est c'était assez difficile
mais il a eu des difficultés à monter le
film pendant deux ans ça a été repris
par un autre producteur et deux ans
après et bien j'étais libre quand il est
venu me reparler du film cette fois ci
en faisant bien le scénario donc à
l'origine il m'avait juste dit qu'il
faisait une comédie musicale je
connaissais rien de l'histoire cette
histoire qu'est ce qui vous a touché
si une histoire très très très riche
c'est une histoire très lumineuse très
sombre en même temps les personnages
sont très complexes et puis j'aimais le
un des thèmes principaux du film qui
était pour moi en tout cas c'est comment
on est transformé comment on est guidé
comment on peut être détruit par par le
besoin de reconnaissance qu'on partage à
peu près tous on a besoin de la
reconnaissance de ses parents de base si
on n'a pas cela crée des peurs des
frustrations des pathologies pour plus
tard dans sa vie d'adulte
et c'est deux personnages qui ont été
confrontés à ça
mes personnages date and driver r11
humoriste célèbre est le mien à nous de
franoux qui est une grande cantatrice et
puis va y avoir une
une chute de l'un une encore plus grande
ascension de l'autre ce que ça va créer
à l'intérieur de ces personnes ce que ça
va créer dans leur couple est ce que ça
va déclencher de sombres et de
destructeurs de leur part envers leur
leurs enfants parce qu'ils vont avoir
une petite fille cette fille annette et
aussi évidemment l'arrivée d'un enfant
dans le couple c'est 6 h
oui à salon est aussi il ya aussi le
fait d'avoir pour à prendre soin d'une
personne quand on a du mal à prendre
soin de soi même quand on a du mal à
passer mais comment on aime l'autre et
comment on aime la chair de sa chair
comment on ne projette pas sur cet
enfant tout son désastre intérieure et
donc c'est vrai qu'elle arrive dans un
couple passionnel mais aussi
dysfonctionnelle
comment c'était aussi pour vous de
pénétrer l'univers de lui oscar à ce
qu'un faiseur d'image incroyable
alors bon j'avais vu tous ses films que
j'aime passionnément et je me doutais
disons même si j'ai jamais d'à priori
que que c'était quelqu'un d' intenses
qui met beaucoup d'un team dans ses
films et effectivement avec un univers
visuel extrêmement fort donc j'étais
très très excité par l'idée de commencer
le film et j'ai jamais été déçu au
contraire il y avait des surprises tous
les jours chaque jour quand j'arrivais
sur le plateau je découvrais des choses
que je n'avais pas imaginé
donc ça peut être déstabilisant parfois
et en même temps sa garde cette énergie
vitale ça donne envie de revenir le jour
d'après et c'est ce qui va c'est que ça
va maintenant
et d'ailleurs est un vrai challenge sur
ce film puisque toutes les chansons sont
live serre que vous tourniez vous
chantiez en même temps et c'est une
vraie prouesse d'actrice d'arriver à
personne alors évidemment c'est
merveilleux de pouvoir chanter en live
parce que comme tout le film et chanter
si on avait suivi le schéma d'une
comédie musicale classique où
généralement on enregistre les chansons
en studio et ensuite on fait un playback
sur le plateau on aurait tout fait en
playback
donc je pense que ça aurait été
extrêmement frustrant et en même temps
de chanter en mouvement et des
mouvements qui n'obtient mise pas du
tout le champ ça va ça a ses difficultés
en même temps c'est aussi ce que les
oscars axe cherchait c'est-à-dire
l'accident l'imperfection qui va donner
une vie différente
à la manière de chanter et donc voilà il
a fallu que j'accepte parfois de que ce
soit pas totalement parfait on va parler
du festival de cannes nous est souvent
venu au festival de cannes c'est
toujours une émotion particulière de
monter les marches à cannes
oui oui j'adore ce festival
effectivement j'ai la chance d'y aller
tous les ans quasiment depuis dix ans et
et je me sens ouais je me sens très
chanceuse là en plus de réouvrir quelque
part ce festival avec un film si
puissant avec un film cinématographique
avec un film qui dans sa première scène
invite les gens dans une aventure
cinématographique
je trouve ça assez parfait et donc je
suis très très heureuse où il n'y a pas
je serai jamais blasé je pense de
devenir à came de venir à coeur merci
beaucoup mario mercier
[Musique]